та вибори на донбасі провести і кордон
між україною і то росію pid контроль
взятим президент Білорусі Олександр
лукашенко заявив, що можна пострілу від
нас ході україни тільки на прізвисько червоними
клей трохи за словом та німецьких експерти
онука шинку завдяки мінським переговорам
вдалося дільничному за заняттям а
ліза 1 батька у складні та ситуації там і
нам а гаїті
треба так ти просто б його балансу аніме
сходам і за ходом полетиш на було
успішним
олени мало економічних на вершки but
when u ту ж погоні та фінансової
ситуації а не за рахунок
вони росія розбирати а поки що треба ватою
моя кицька багнет йти заяви один зело
способі провернути цю силу у flac
але думка експертів захист україна нас
приймає лукашенка якона зарічного граф
цілий міжнародної політики і ми
погодіть вона не вояка на об'єктивно
кажучи стегна ведмедика і вам і москвою у
всіх вуличний комітет
він шукав і в проект резолюції про
доручення про закохані в окупованому
криму
Білорусі кірасі я проголосувала проти
мінськ ідею фарватері Москви і буду
продовжи ці роботи лукашенко але
адже і сам на тему завжди нам краще
засіки номіналу rich низу зустрічі з
путіним
я не перший рік я не поспішаючи ерік
президентом проти
і на 10 років на 15, а вже 20 роки
а за зараз уже можна було при свічці тис
а в наших поворотах і розворотах там
не треба нам дерек від ще ми кудись
розпусти та мій
набагато куди розпусти тисами свами
завжди був разом і буду матчі долара за
що довго разом, з приматами
ініціатива лукашенка морем такі ви
Москву серйозно поважають експерти
раніше я як так так у кремля цілих ряду
століття на готовий сигнал збоку росіян чого
Неджі дозволяють на норманський процес
сект ok можна його лукашенком і
сигналізацію заміну російської позиції
ще до поговоримо про нормандський у
процесі а про позиція лукашенка
провести вибори на донбасі та заходив
розсмішив абата тек захисних експертів
аджуссі проводами в Білорусі вибір ще
раз уп'ялася піцу мені в міжнародному
з постере хоча ми за крима та
президентським вона
уроку на і кік лукашенка
безальтернативно парі my side as with
батьки
на гречі корисливий для Європи